we had a look at we tried to position
the context of this
topic by saying um extension two motion
is just like extension one motion but we
added something what did we add
we added mass good so just like before
we had
displacement right and its units were
say liters
that's standard right then when we
differentiated just like the question we
just did
right you get velocity and you
differentiate with respect to time so
what units would you associate with
velocity
meters per second right and then you go
one more time you're still
differentiating with respect to time so
you get another time unit
on the denominator so far so good okay
and then we added mass into the picture
we thought okay let's just think about
kilograms as our basic unit
okay so then we said if you take
velocity and you bring mass into play
right
what did we call that we had a name
sorry displacement velocity
acceleration mass what was this chord
momentum good and its units were
kilogram meters per second because it
was this
times mass right and then we did the
same thing and this is the um
this is the force that we've been
familiar with okay now because this is
such an important unit that's why we
gave it the main mutants
okay but now here's the important thing
and here's where the new concept comes
in
okay newtons newtons one newton
is equivalent to one of these okay so
let's try to unpack that
one newton
okay it's the amount of force the amount
of force
required to do what
well the units themselves tell you okay
it's the force required to move
one kilogram or to accelerate rather
one kilogram
how much how much well there's still no
other numbers in here right
so it'll be sorry it'll be one kilogram
one meter per one second per one second
right so to accelerate one kilogram
at one meter per second squared
now this is all fine and good and when
we're in kind of like
you know made up mathematics land where
we just sort of here's an equation and
here are numbers and it's a cubic
where did this come from it doesn't
matter it's just imagine right
but when you come into the real world
this is kind of
well it's not that there's a more common
sort of
uh acceleration that we have to deal
with that comes into all sorts of
questions and we've already been dealing
with it in extension one motion
namely not one meter per second squared
but 9.8
meters per second squared now where does
this number come from
it comes from gravity right now we've
dealt with this under projectile motion
already okay but if you think about
the same idea but instead of one kilo at
one meter per second per second
but if you make it one kilo at
9.8 meters per second per second right
this is not a newton anymore like this
is exactly
9.8 times bigger than a newton but this
is the force that results
from gravity at least gravity on our
planet okay
so rather than newtons they introduced
this i'll just
stay with this introduce this thing
it comes up in the exercise right so
rather than thinking about okay just
mutants which
you know these are just kind of out in
mid-air no context
when you are thinking about earth and
you're thinking about the gravity
right this is the force
that's uh required
to accelerate a kilo at this rate which
is exactly
the rate that the earth does okay by the
way just as a side note
um i don't know if you've heard how in
science in physics there's all these
forces fundamental forces right and they
say gravity
it's super super weak right it's the
weakest of the lot
okay but we experience it all the time
why is it that the weakest force is the
one that we're actually most familiar
with and the answer is
to get to this right
what does this what is this based on
where does this come from
think back to our laws of motion right
this force
and the corresponding acceleration it
comes from whatever is exerting that
force which in this case is
it's it's the earth
there you go there's australia that's
awful sorry you get the idea
now the earth is huge
the earth is enormous right all of this
mass is required to exert this
acceleration okay and this particular
number is the number that we're
interested in
so when you see one kilogram weight it's
its own unit
and because it's exactly 9.8 times
bigger than
a newton right it's equal to 9.8
newtons okay so you will see both of
these units
kilograms weight and newtons and you
need to be able to
recognize and convert